Hi, I’m Christine Quinn,
queen of real estate
TITLE: QUEEN OF REAL ESTATE
and star of Selling Sunset.
Obviously I want to make a million
dollar commission, who wouldn't?
There’s too many bitches in this office.
Opulent high-end homes are
my thing.
That’s why my good friend Lana
gave me the keys,
so I can give you an exclusive tour
of the all new
Too Hot To Handle luxury villa.
TITLE: SELLING TOO HOT TO HANDLE
Welcome to paradise.
This villa is situated just next
to the beautiful Caribbean
on Turks and Caicos Islands.
A beauty spot perfect for
long periods of reflection,
abstinence and
talking to an AI programmed robot.
Indeed.
As you enter the property you’re
met with super glam furnishings
in a bright and well lit space.
Perfect for seeing your roommates
for who they really are.
And now, where all the magic
usually happens.
Although ten guests share this bedroom,
they can wave goodbye to getting
steamy with their hot roommates.
And only if you abide by Lana’s rules,
there’s a private suite available.
You’re gonna love this bathroom.
You can enjoy a soak after
a long day of abstaining
in this gorge oversized stone
bathtub that will definitely
get your temperature rising.
Time for my favorite room
in the entire villa...
The glam room!
Here you’ll find a six-seater dressing
area with full-length mirrors,
so you can check yourself
out at every angle.
Outside there’s plenty to enjoy in
these dreamy island temperatures.
There’s also a workshop
and meditation area
perfect for harnessing
your inner chi.
Hi there, Christine.
Hey, Lana.
Thank you for checking
out the new villa.
Your expertise in this field
is much appreciated.
You’re more than welcome, queen.
This fabulous villa is one
hundred percent
Christine Quinn approved.